[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
victor il arrive en courant ce
dealer de s'abonner atlantique toc
abonnez-vous à monter
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
ça me rappelle la tournée d'argentan
qu'elle part en plus c'est sale
c'est moi
[Rires]
j'ai un petit garçon ici si
ça va c'est bien une bonne expérience de
jouer dans les eaux marines gardien
c'est super bien tu es heureux ouais
ouais
je vous présente max et marc bonjour
attention va demander le moteur c'est le
coeur des gens des blâmes hauteurs de
mende et
les amis aujourd'hui je teste un filtre
apparemment ce filtre de la taille de
ton bangala on va voir si ça marche
attends ce rocher choqué je crois que ça
marche bleue mais moi j'en ai
les clés normes j'ai 26 ans non
[Musique]